welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and thrawn is the new Big Bad of
the Star Wars universe as the
Mandalorian season 3 pivots toward
Ahsoka all these storylines headed to
their own crossover film directed by
Dave filoni thrawn is being played by
Mars Mickelson who voiced the character
in Star Wars Rebels and brother to Galen
urso actor mads Mickelson the character
was last seen in Rebels on his Star
Destroyer of the Chimera disappearing
into hyperspace with Ezra Bridger thanks
to a group of pergol hyperspace whales
now you probably picked up on bits and
pieces of thrawn's backstory but let us
all now get on the same page what is
thrawn's real history and why is he so
desperately needed in Star Wars right
now well I'm gonna break down thrawn's
complete history his publication history
and legends literature his returns and
Rebels and live action and what exact
role he's going to be playing in these
upcoming titles simply put thrawn is the
smartest tactician in the Star Wars
universe and we need him to expose how
dumb everyone else is so that they can
prove their heroism wise up finally and
truly earn the affection we feel for
them don't get me wrong I love these
soft knees but they've just been getting
enough easy and I think filoni knows it
and he's about to hit everyone with the
fist of a chiss thrawn was first
introduced in 1991. Timothy zahn's novel
heir to the Empire the first of Zan's
thrawn Trilogy this was an important
time for Star Wars fandom because it was
eight years after Return of the Jedi
eight years before The Phantom Menace
creating really the perfect void for a
new face to claim the Throne of the
fandom and thrawn activated the
popularity of the expanded universe lore
in a way really nothing else had before
in these books thrawn was introduced as
a genius Naval Commander for the Empire
the kind of Sherlock Holmes figure with
his captain peleon as is Watson peleon
actually showed up in the Mandalorian
chapter 23 played by Xander Berkeley and
in these books we saw hethron
outmaneuvered the new Republic really a
thorn in the side of Admiral Akbar
during the years after Return of the
Jedi nearly killing Admiral Akbar until
he was assassinated by a bodyguard in
the final of the three books the last
command in Legends and in Canon thrawn
is never defeated due to being outwitted
or outstrategized only by treachery or
unforeseen acts of God like
hyperspace whales now sometimes these
sponsorships are me talking about hair
care but to even get to caring about
your hair you gotta hang on to the hair
that you got and that's what keeps this
for Keeps offers clinically proven in
research-backed treatments to stop hair
loss and improve hair growth two out of
three guys will experience hair loss by
the time they're 35 but with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or a pharmacy
all keeps treatment plans are
recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy each treatment plan
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
medical provider about anything anytime
keep says a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair that you have keep says you
covered hair loss stops with keeps to
get a special offer go to keeps.com new
rockstars or just click the link in the
description that's keps.com new
rockstars so in 2015 Disney bought
lucasfilm and they re-categorized all
expanded universe fiction as Legends and
thus non-canon but in the years since
Dave filoni and his story group have
gradually begun to recanonize Legends
elements in titles like Rebels the
Mandalorian the book of boba fed and
Ahsoka and thrawn naturally was the
first of these brought in as the primary
antagonist in Rebels season 3 in season
four and from here a broader range in a
new generation of fans began to
understand how truly great thrawn is as
an imperial Grand Admiral during the
Empire chasing down the crew of the
ghost on lothal as he used this planet
as a base to build his new Thai
Defenders his Hope was to construct the
fleet of Fighters with better shielding
and had he been successful the rebels
would not have been able to destroy the
Death Star in the Battle of Yavin Tarkin
would have blown up the rebel based on
Gavin 4 and that would have been it
that's part of the reason thrawn is such
a threat he is the smartest guy in the
room heading up and zipped away to
hyperspace the rebels probably would not
have won so during this Rebels era
viewers got to see how he's able to
decode his enemies by learning about
their culture through their art as is
the case when he captured Harrison Dilla
and appreciated her twilik art to defeat
an enemy you must know them not simply
that battle of tactics but the history
philosophy
odds he was also able to get inside Ezra
preacher's head by just learning more
and more about his background on the
fall really his intelligence comes from
a new canonical backstory outlined in a
new Trilogy of thrawn books thrawn
ascendancy and they brought back the
amazing original author Timothy Zahn to
do it this details thrawn's backstory
here he was born on the planet rental in
the unknown regions birth name Ki Buran
Nuru core name Duron the chiss race
through this really cool thing of
abbreviating names from the inside out
as opposed to taking the first part
which definitely says something about
how complex the thinkers all the chits
are they think of everything
holistically from the inside out he
later took on the name of Mithra narodo
or thrawn and he was an officer for the
chiss ascendancy which was a smaller
Empire ruled by an oligarchy class of
chis during the Clone Wars thrawn
actually briefly worked with Anakin
Skywalker on a mission on Batu that's
the setting of The Black Spire Outpost
in Disney's Galaxy's Edge when the Clone
Wars ended thrawn offered his services
to the Empire believing that it would
benefit the chiss in reality thrawn
joined the Empire with dual loyalties
actually intending to learn as much as
he could about the Imperial weaknesses
and their overall strategy so that he
could use to help his home raise the
chiss but thrawn quickly rose up the
ranks and was granted the title of grand
Admiral by Palpatine himself which was a
huge deal because the empire was known
to be xenophobic and only promote humans
to high-ranking positions so like
compare all the Admirals and moths and
Generals that we know the Empire to the
folks who lead the rebels non-humans
like Admiral Radice Admiral Akbar
Harrison Doula so for thrawn Rise past
all of that as a chiss shows how
respected he was thrawn ascendancy also
shows how thrawn was able to deduce said
Darth Vader and Anakin Skywalker were
the same person in One Moment Ron says
tellingly many years ago I served
briefly alongside General Anakin
Skywalker Invader uses the force to try
to read thrawn's mind but finds thrawn's
thoughts closed off to him hmm in
another moment thrawn talks about that
old clone wars Mission and says that we
once assaulted before correcting himself
and then another moment from thrawn's
point of view he watched Vader pilot a
tie Defender spinning the fighter in a
tight curve doing a complete role it's a
familiar maneuver carried out with a
familiar Precision it is he referring to
Anna kid's favorite barrel roll move
that he showed while piloting the Jedi
Starfighter in the Battle of Coruscant
at the beginning of Revenge of the Sith
so now in these live action titles
Ahsoka Tano first brought up thrawn's
name in the Mandalorian chapter 13
demanding of thrawn's servant the
magistrate Morgan Ellsworth where is
Grand Admiral thrawn clearly Ahsoka is
still searching for Ezra Bridger after
she and Sabine written teamed up at the
end of rebels a search that looks like
it's going to get renewed in the Ahsoka
series thrawn appeared in the trailer
for this Ahsoka spin-off series shown
only from behind but a frontal image of
thrawn's face was shown exclusively to
fans in celebration and in these final
episodes of the Mandalorian season 3
Bronze Protege Captain Gilead peleon
appeared in moff Gideon's Shadow Council
of Imperial Warlords insisting that they
need thrawn's return to Rally the
scattered Imperial supporters across the
Galaxy to their cause the Way in real
world history armies would use
mythologized commanders like George
Washington or Robert E Lee as
recruitment tools MAF Gideon dismissed
the still missing thrawn as a ghost but
thrawn is clearly coming back so why is
this such a big deal now well we need
someone actually smart and actually
competent in the room to really change
challenge these Heroes and challenge the
villains we've met so far between the
New Republic bungling the management of
the Galaxy the mandalorians constantly
endangering themselves and MOB Gideon's
ridiculous arrogance we need a villain
of the cunning of the ISB boardroom
scenes in Andor to really make us fear
these characters specifically we need a
military strategist without a cultish
subservience to Palpatine or a fear of
Palpatine's ghost thrawn stands in no
one's Shadow he's truly the ghost we
should be afraid of because when someone
says somehow Brawn returned I don't
think anybody's gonna be laughing hey
next Friday April 21st we'll begin my
re-watch series of Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 1 volume 2 on the Deep dive
channel so please subscribe to that
channel and keep an eye out for those
you can support our growing Network by
grabbing something for our merch store
nerd riot.shop subscribe to new
rockstars on YouTube and on all social
platforms follow me at eavos thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you